Now, it’s possible you haven’t
noticed all the wicked ways
these snowflakes and soy boys
are sabotaging Halloween.
So I’ve invited some
of our citizen journalists
to share some scary stories,
submitted for the approval
of the 30 Minutes
to Midnight Society.
♪ ♪
Our first tale tonight
comes from Aaron and Josh,
who are dressed as Don Jr.
and Eric Trump.
Um...
(clears throat) No.
-Jordan, uh...
-(cheering and applause)
Sorry, no.
A-Actually, Jordan, we’re, uh...
we’re sexy Don Jr.
-A-And slutty Eric Trump.
-Yeah.
You’re gonna be terrified
of how aroused you are!
You’re gonna be so aroused,
Mike Pence is gonna send you
to conversion therapy.
Our story is called...
BOTH: "The Tale
of the Brainwashed School."
Halloween
is now considered too--
and I’m quoting--
non-inclusive to be celebrated
in at least two elementary
schools in Massachusetts.
Boyden Elementary School
will be replacing Halloween with
Black and Orange spirit day!
Anthony, this is insane!
-It’s... -They say they’re doing
it because it’s not inclusive
-of all students. There is no
more inclusive holiday -Right.
than Halloween. Everyone gets
to participate in Halloween.
Yes, Jordan! Everyone is allowed
to trick-or-treat!
Except for some religious kids
and diabetic kids
and childless drunk adults,
apparently.
Thanks for the ankle bracelet,
State of New York!
-Honestly, you wear it well.
(clears throat) -Thank you.
But, Jordan, that’s the problem
with inclusivity--
the PC police are so scared
of leaving one person out,
now no one gets Halloween...
during school hours.
Once they go home,
then everyone gets Halloween.
-But, still, it’s spooky...!
-Ooh... -Ooh.
-(applause and cheering)
-Terrifying stuff.
Terrifying. The last time
I was that frightened,
I trusted Nate Silver
as a legitimate polling source.
(laughter)
(Hillary laughing)
(thunder rumbling)
Niccole, you look positively
horrifying.
Exactly, Jordan.
I’m a holiday Starbucks cup
that doesn’t say "Christmas."
-Oh.
-(laughter)
As you can see, I put the "hot"
in "boyc-hot Starbucks.
(laughter)
-(applause)
-But listen...
Not everyone thinks Halloween is
about looking fabulous.
Just listen to the tale
of the P.C. Costume Killer!
WOMAN: Halloween now becoming
more politically correct
as college campuses
try and dictate
what students can
and cannot dress up as.
Wesleyan University
putting up these posters,
asking if your costume
is offensive.
MAN:
Is it okay for people
to dress up
like an American Indian?
And I thought multiculturalism
was a good thing.
Can a liberal dress up as
Barack Obama if you’re white?
I don’t even want to go there.
Okay, I’ll go there.
(laughter)
And I’m gonna wear what I want.
Halloween is about embracing
fantastical personas,
like Jedi, or ninja, or Latina.
(laughter)
Now, I know all these colleges
might be putting up posters
that say, "Niccole,
you don’t understand the history
"behind what you are wearing.
You are treating
someone’s heritage as a joke!"
And to that I say,
this is not a joke!
I am seriously
killing this kimono.
-(laughter)
-But...
What better way to respect a
culture than by walking a mile
in someone else’s shoes,
and getting blackout drunk
in their skin tone?
(laughter)
It is an homage.
That’s French
for "showing respect."
-KLEPPER: Wow. Yes.
-Oui. Oui.
The sensitivity from the left
is more frightening
than when I found my ex’s NPR
tote bag lurking under my bed.
But I want to really get chills,
so let’s see
what Kobi has for us.
-(Hillary laughing)
-(thunder rumbling)
She’s spooky.
Hello, Jordan.
I’m obviously the DNC receipt
for the Clinton Russia dossier.
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
And the scariest thing
about my costume is
how little the mainstream media
is covering it.
Kobi, I don’t know
if I can take another story
about whiny liberals
getting all triggered
at a fun, made-up holiday
about goofs and pranks.
-They’re so sensitive! -Yeah,
they’re way too sensitive!
-They need to relax!
-It’s just a holiday!
And here
you’ve got another story
of some super-sensitive liberals
who are freaking out
over some itty-bitty
Halloween thing.
Actually, this one is about
anti-Trump lawn decorations.
How dare they!
On Halloween?
(laughter)
Let me set the scene.
A Halloween display
in New York sparking outrage.
It says,
"D. Trump, burn in hell"
is what is written
on a tombstone.
(cheers and applause)
We’ll never know.
We’ll never know
which "D. Trump"
this tombstone refers to, but,
Jordan,
I think it might be Donald.
Kobi, I don’t like this one.
I don’t like this one at all.
First of all, it’s wrong.
D. Trump is not going to hell.
He’s going to heaven, minimum.
That’s not even the worst part,
Jordan.
That tombstone is pitting
neighbors against neighbor,
tweeter against tweeter.
Fighting about politics
on Halloween
as if it were thanksgiving,
or any day on Facebook.
Okay... Kobi...
what are you saying?
This is one, big liberal ploy
to ruin yet another holiday.
Pretty soon, we’ll be saying,
"Happy October 31st"
instead of "Merry Halloween!"
(Klepper screams
in high-pitched tone)